i first learned that i was a nazi many
years ago i don't remember what the
opinion was exactly but i expressed some
kind of opinion about something and i
was promptly informed that only nazis
think that way or say those sorts of
things
of course the confusing part was that my
opinion had nothing at all to do with
nazism or anything associated with
nazism
nonetheless i was a nazi and like so
many others i have relearned this lesson
every day since
these days i'm called a nazi dozens of
times every hour of every day i'm a nazi
for criticizing joe biden i'm a nazi for
opposing critical race theory i'm a nazi
for believing that men can't have babies
i'm a nazi for not wanting preschool
teachers to talk to four-year-olds about
their sexuality i'm a nazi for saying
that fat people should consider dieting
i'm a nazi for preferring vanilla ice
cream over chocolate etc and so forth on
and on forever
and i'm not just a nazi again as so many
of you have learned about yourselves i'm
also every ist and phobe in the book i'm
a sexist a transphobe a homophobe a fat
foe but misogynist an ableist a fascist
a white supremacist and so on
every week i learned that i'm guilty of
new moral crimes that i didn't even know
existed before last week i was a
a massage noir which apparently is a
racist misogyny a racist racist misogyny
against black women is misogynor and i'm
guilty of that too it turns out
my super villain resume continues to
grow
i am indeed the worst nazi white
supremacist fat phobe ableist anti-gay
fascist transphobic misogynoris
misogynist homophobe the world has ever
seen
along with all the other nazi white
supremacists fat phobe ableist anti-gay
fascists transphobic misogynoris
misogynist homophobes there are a lot of
us out there half the country if not
more
at least that's what we have been told
that's how we've been labeled
we've been labeled this way relentlessly
non-stop in response to literally every
view we hold everything we say every
argument we make and every opinion we
express
so you must forgive me if i am not very
sympathetic to the leftist who are now
complaining about being labeled groomers
these are the very people who have hung
every smear slur and label under the sun
around my neck and yours for decades
they've literally accused us of being
secret agents of the third reich and now
they insist that we
should be more careful with the labels
that we use
your accusations are unfair and hurtful
you damn nazi klansmen
they say as they wipe tears away
so you'll excuse me if i struggle to
take their emotions seriously
and yet this is the response they're
going with
over the last several days in response
especially to conservative criticism of
contanji jackson's lenience towards
pedophiles and our push for parental
rights in florida and elsewhere
the media have declared that grooming
accusations are unfair despicable
shameful
the kinds of things that only nazis say
the washington post has an article
headlined the new red scare the right
leans into pedophilia accusations
and then vice declares conservatives are
smearing don't say gay opponents as
pedophile groomers
the week wonders why are republicans so
concerned about grooming
because it's bad i think probably just
answer it that way
new york magazine has a long piece
explaining quote why republicans are
smearing everyone as pedophiles now
josh marshall at talking points memo
goes farther he says that um the groomer
accusation is quote pre-genocide talk so
now we're genocidal
but we're the ones again we should be
careful with the labels right
and there's of course round agreement
that the grooming claims are really
thinly veiled homophobia as the daily
beast explains in their article
republicans say groomer to put a nice
face on homophobia
that article by the way written by
daniel summers says in part read a
little bit of this dude says by reaching
for the language of sexual predation to
be wielded against lgbtq plus people and
our supporters and decrying this law
people calling us groomers make plain
that the hatred never really left
the same hideous lies that inform the
taunts of my childhood bullies are near
at hand for use today of course what we
really want is nothing like the vicious
falsehood imputed to us i don't want my
own young children learning about sex
straight or gay or otherwise before it's
developmentally appropriate any more
than any other parent does
what i do want is for them to be able to
talk about their two dads in the same
easy way their peers with heterosexual
parents talk about their families and
for their teachers to be able to
participate in guiding those discussions
if necessary i want families like ours
to show up in the books available in my
class or in the classrooms so both my
kids and the other students can see that
we exist alongside them
i want kids who don't conform to other
people's gender expectations to be safe
and supported in their classrooms just
the way they are
once again
they are the ones who assume that any
accusation of grooming must be a
reference to lgbt people
we never said that perhaps this writer
has some guilt on his own conscience
that makes him leap to that conclusion i
have no idea what i do know
is that all the florida bill does and
all that any of us are calling for as it
relates to this topic is a prohibition
of sexually inappropriate classroom
instruction that's it
we are not saying that gay people are
the only ones who give this kind of
inappropriate instruction we don't care
who's giving it
the who is not important
it's the what
and as for that what the writer claims
that he agrees that children shouldn't
learn about sex before it's
developmentally appropriate but then
in the next sentence
he says that he wants teachers to guide
discussions about his children's two
dads
now there's nothing in the bill
preventing his children from talking
about their home life but
why do you need the teachers to guide
that discussion what does that mean
i don't recall any of my teachers in any
grade in any classroom guiding
discussions about our personal lives
the phrasing here is quite bizarre and
it leads inevitably to the conclusion
that in fact he does want teachers
giving sexually
inappropriate instruction to young
children even as he claims otherwise
but according to the left the groomer
label is not only a vicious hurtful
smear
it's also of course a conspiracy theory
chris hayes on msnbc laid this out uh
last night listen to this
these republican politicians and their
allies in conservative media cannot just
come out and say
there is an evil cabal of liberals
running a child sex trafficking ring
around the world dominated by george
soros the rothschilds and the clintons
and they also worship satan they realize
they sound nuts
so instead they find these not so clever
ways to play footsie with the people
that do believe that that make up at
least a quarter of the base of their
party
like
accusing judge jackson of being
sympathetic to child abusers wink wink
or adopting the slogan
save the children which of course sounds
perfectly noble innocent enough on its
face but as associate press reports has
actually become a dog whistle to q anon
supporters
or more recently through vague
allegations of
grooming
an age-old smear to imply that members
of lgbtq community are trying to prime
children for sexual abuse
that appears to be the case in florida
and the basis behind the state's
so-called don't say gay bill which
prohibits the discussion the discussion
in class of sexual orientation or gender
identity
in classrooms for young children
just to clarify one thing first of all
um
we are not saying that liberals and
democrats
worship satan
uh they are satanists yes but they
worship themselves and satanism is the
worship of the self so but yeah i mean
absolutely satanic they they are
and so are you chris hayes
that's all a dog whistle to q anon uh he
says never mind that at this point q
anon is comprised of about four people
posting memes back and forth on a
message board somewhere
the irony is that hayes demonstrates the
leftist propensity for smearing and
labeling their opponents even while
decrying the alleged smearing and
labeling of his own side
he says that anybody wants to save the
children or who opposes inappropriate
sexual discussion in kindergarten is a
proponent of the q anon conspiracy
theory
and they're also nazis of course
meanwhile even some alleged
conservatives have locked arms with
leftists like chris hayes in an attempt
to shield them from the groomer tag
david french of course
um
usual suspect posted an article titled
against the groomer smear now i didn't
read it because it's behind a paywall
that i'm definitely not paying for but
we can assume that french's argument
boils down to this tweet that he sent
out earlier the same day he says
redefining grooming and slinging false
accusations of sympathy for pedophilia
is pure malice
blue checks doing it on this website
know better but lots of ordinary folks
don't
they hear the words and apply their
ordinary meaning
that's incredibly dangerous
this is malice it's dangerous
inappropriate
that's david french's whole career at
this point is wagging his finger and
saying in a inappropriate
now you have to love this from david
frenchman it's it's the perfect mix of
whimpish cow towing hypocritical
dishonesty and pompous paternalism
ordinary folks are too stupid to
understand what is meant by groomer he
says
he's standing up for those ordinary
folks or just morons
and his sentiments are echoed by others
that allege conservative publications
like the dispatch and bulwark
you can't be surprised to see these
folks taking this position i mean they
represent a brand of conservatism that
has achieved nothing of significance i
mean it has presided over the left's
total domination of the culture
it has watched haplessly and helplessly
as left-wing radicals took over every
major cultural institution to include
and especially the educational
institutions
it has at best slowed our civilizational
descent into the abyss but probably not
even managed that much
and now that it sees a brand of
conservatism that is actually landing
some blows here you know winning back
some of the ground that was lost ever so
slowly ever so
you know um
inch by inch
now that it sees this brand conservative
achieving what it could never achieve
the proponents of this ineffectual
effeminate brand of conservatism perhaps
out of envy or simply weakness or some
combination
they run to the left
becoming outright defenders of what they
had previously spent decades pretending
to oppose
they hate the groomer label especially
because it works
and these faux conservatives hate
nothing so much as what actually works
and that's what we have to understand
about groomer the label
first of all even if the label was
unfair
the people complaining about its
unfairness have no room to complain
their tears mean nothing
they have smeared and lied and slandered
and defamed with abandon for years on
end
they're now getting a dose of their own
medicine
and if that's the case
and they don't like it they have only
themselves to blame
but as it happens
the label is not unfair
it is simply an undeniable fact
that leftist radicals in education and
in media and in hollywood and in
government are now and have been for
years indoctrinating and grooming kids
into a certain sexual view and lifestyle
that is precisely how lgbt and trans
identifications have increased
exponentially in just a short period of
time
that is why there's now an epidemic of
kids confused about their genders it's
why the identity crisis has gotten so
bad that they're putting litter boxes in
public school bathrooms for kids who
identify as felines
this is all the result of grooming
it's what they're doing
it's what they've done
and they hate it when we point it out
which is why we must continue to do so
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content